Marvel's bigwigs have a knack for
top-notch casting and black panther the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is 2018
venture into the kingdom of Wakanda is
no exception
this film sprawling cast includes
familiar faces and new additions to the
MCU and as you may have already noticed
many of wakanda's heroes and villains
look and sound very familiar let's take
a look at where you've already seen the
talented men and women behind Marvel's
black panther Chadwick Boseman T'Challa
Black Panther as king of the isolated
Kingdom of Wakanda and the man behind
the black panther mask
T'Challa has become both the political
and literal protector of his people
following the death of his father -
Chaka during the events of Captain
America Civil War so we'd say he
probably has a few more responsibilities
than the average guy T'Challa
actor chadwick boseman has appeared in a
number of hugely successful biopics
portraying Jackie Robinson and 42 James
Brown and get on up and a young Thurgood
Marshall in the aptly titled Marshall
but the British American drama Academy
graduate got his start with a series of
minor roles and procedural dramas and
soaps in the early 2000s in 2010 he
landed his first recurring role on the
psychological drama persons unknown not
bad especially considering bozeman who's
also a playwright initially wanted to
stick to writing interacting Danai
gurira a co a a co a may seem like a
newcomer to Marvel fans who stick to the
flicks but in the comics she plays a
pivotal role in the survival of not only
to Chawla himself but the whole of
Wakanda as a member of the reinstated
Doraemon logic the Challis personal
order of bodyguards Akoya is tasked with
protecting Black Panther at all costs
even if he doesn't look like he needs
much protection it's no surprise that
actress did Nigeria's Marvel counterpart
looks like she knows how to handle
herself with a deadly weapon after all
she trained with a legit sword master in
preparation to play me shown on AMC's
The Walking Dead
she's also shown off the acting chops
she developed at the Tisch School of the
Arts going on to portray one half of a
Nigerian couple struggling through
fertility issues in the 2013 drama
mother of George she'd returned to the
big screen in the 2017 biopic all eyes
on me playing a Phoenicia core
mother of late rapper Tupac Shakur
Michael B Jordan Erik Stephens kill
monger when Erik Stephens chose his
supervillain pseudonym
he must have been the last thing on his
mind we all know what kind of message a
guy with the name kill monger is trying
to get across a former Black Ops soldier
with a vendetta against a chawla kill
monger finds himself teaming up with
arms dealer Klaw in his quest for the
wakandan throne if you've got any taste
in TV you'll immediately recognize actor
Michael B Jordan from his portrayal of
Wallace in the wire following his season
long stint on the HBO hit Jordan took
his talents to Friday Night Lights
joining the cast for its fourth and
fifth seasons as Vince Howard in 2013
Jordan worked with future black panther
director Ryan Coogler portraying
shooting victim Oscar Grant in 2015's
Fruitvale station he later earned
acclaim for his work in the rocky
spin-off Creed and star in the ill-fated
Fantastic Four reboot but we don't need
to talk about that here Lupita Nyong'o
Nakia like a coy a Nakia is a member of
the Dora Malaysia but rather than
remaining by King to chalice side the
Blade wielding spies sneaks around the
globe gathering Intel to keep the
isolated nation of Wakanda protected and
informed actress Lupita Nyong'o got her
first big break in the heart-rending 12
years of slave which snagged the young
star an Oscar for Best Supporting
Actress
but sci-fi and fantasy fans will most
likely recognize her as the voice of Maz
Kanata in the Star Wars sequel trilogy
she also provided a vocal performance
for the jungle books Raksha
Wolfmother de Mowgli in the 2016
live-action reimagining Forest Whitaker
Zuri drawing comparisons to Star Wars
obi-wan Kenobi
Zuri is a spiritual figure akin to a
shaman with strong links to - child's
father - Chaka part of the Black
Panthers inner circle
Zuri plays many roles including advisor
mentor and spiritual guide to the young
wakandan King Forest Whitaker is an
actor renowned for his adaptability in
other words no matter what kind of films
you're into chances are you've seen this
brilliant actor somewhere dig a gruesome
gritty historical piece every now and
then you'll recognize Whitaker from his
portrayal of former ugandan president
idi amin in 2008's The Last King of
Scotland and as genre-bending hip hop
samurai blood baths no prob you'll know
him as the titular character from Jim
Jarmusch's Ghost Dog the way of the
samurai and as his appearance in Black
Panther attests he isn't adverse to the
occasional blockbuster in fact he was
recently seen in a galaxy far far away
training the gorilla rebel known as saw
Guerrera in rogue one a Star Wars story
Angela Bassett Ramon de the recently
widowed Queen Mother of Wakanda
Ramona has seen better days since the
death of her late husband and former
wakandan King - Chaka but even in the
face of such personal and political
tragedy cleaner Ramona persists as a
driving force on her son's High Council
Angela Bassett who portrays the wakandan
matriarch and emcee used Black Panther
has cemented herself as a veritable
legend on the big and small screens in
the 90s she starred in a string of
critically acclaimed films like Malcolm
X what's love got to do with it how
Stella got her groove back and Waiting
to Exhale
but Bassett would later bring her
talents to television nabbing big roles
in a number of Ryan Murphy run shows
like American Horror Story and Fox
police procedural 9-1-1 alongside fellow
AHS alum Connie Britton Daniel Kaluga
Maccabi hostile toward outsiders and
endlessly loyal to his allies especially
T'Challa what cobby is a force to be
reckoned with
not only is what cobby Black Panthers
right-hand man but the chief of wakandan
security is also a capable warrior to
boot well copy actor Daniel Kaluga
appeared in a handful of films in the
early 2000s along with a recurring role
in the British drama skins and a
well-received performance in an episode
of Black Mirror but it was a minor role
when 2013's kick-ass 2 as black death
that jump-started his rise to fame he
would go on to become a household name
in 2017 when he starred in the
award-winning psychological thriller get
out Florence kizomba io a member of the
dough rep mila j io leads to chalice
security unit with confidence and poise
introduced to viewers in Captain America
Civil War she nearly came to blows with
Black Widow during a confrontation about
everybody's favorite big cat on campus
while she's appeared in a number of
German shows and movies actress Florence
kizomba is still relatively new to
American film and television the soon to
be star has only appeared in a handful
of productions like 2017 s hugely
successful Wonder Woman movie in which
she played senator Akaka and in 2016
she joined the cast of the short-lived
Emerald City and edgy reimagining of The
Wizard of Oz in which she played the
Wicked Witch of the East latisha ride
Cherie
the chalice half sister Cherie is
definitely a runner-up
biggest badass in Wakanda with super
smarts to rival the likes of Tony Stark
and a penchant for powerful weaponry
like her Panther faced blaster gloves
Sheree isn't afraid to take her
tech-savvy talents to the battlefield
alongside her brother and the DOE
Ramallah Jay let's get one thing
straight latisha right deserves all the
roles she showed that she could lead a
feature film in 2015 when she took
center stage in the award-winning urban
hem in fact 2015 proved to be a huge
year for right not only did she snag a
recurring role in the sci-fi drama
humans but she was also tapped to
portray a central character in the
Doctor Who episode face the Raven while
she's mostly credited with bit roles in
British television shows like top boy
coming up and chasing shadows
she's also starred in the Black Mirror
episode black Museum as nish a visitor
to the titular tourist attraction
Winston Duke in Baku known in the black
panther comics as the super offensively
named man ape baku will thankfully not
be taking his source material pseudonym
when he makes his MCU debut however the
young Jabari tribe leader doesn't look
any less menacing even if he swapped out
his comic counterparts full gorilla hide
suit for more practical armor while
mbaku is a pretty well known and feared
comic book villain the man behind the
tattered breastplate Winston Duke is
relatively new to acting Duke who has a
background in theater began his
television acting career in 2014 when he
guest starred on an episode of Law &
Order Special Victims Unit as a high
school football player that same year
the actor returned to the crime thriller
genre portraying many in a 7 episode arc
of the CBS crime thriller Person of
Interest martin freeman Everett Ross
first introduced in Captain America
Civil War Everett Ross is a CIA
operative and former head of the Joint
Terrorism Task Force in Black Panther
Ross finds himself at odds with the
vibranium hungry ulysses klaw as it
turns out the smuggler isn't exactly
about to go down without a fight
actor Martin Freeman is everywhere from
portraying dr. John H Watson and BBC's
Sherlock opposite fellow MCU or Benedict
Cumberbatch to stepping into the furry
oversized feet of Bilbo Baggins in The
Hobbit trilogy Freeman's filmography
resembles a laundry list of big-name
flicks quirky TV shows and everything in
between after getting his big break on
the British
version of the office Freeman would go
on to star in a number of mostly comedic
films including Edgar Wright's three
flavours Cornetto trilogy and 2005's The
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy in
which he played reluctant and newly
evicted from Earth protagonist Arthur
Dent Andy Serkis ulysses klaw one of the
most exciting new additions to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe has got to be
Ulysses Klaw our resident sociopathic
South African arms dealer who was first
introduced in Avengers age of Ultron
while actor Andy Serkis brings sadistic
charm and a roguish look to the role
comic fans will likely associate the
name Klaw with Marvel's token sonic
disruptor wielding super villain made of
living sound believe it or not mocap
mogul Andy Serkis had only been working
on TV and film for around six years
before Peter Jackson cast him as Gollum
in the Fellowship of the Ring in 2001 it
was this role that inspired the cyber
thespian to dedicate his career or at
least a good chunk of it to motion
capture performance circus reprised his
role as Gollum in Jackson's The Hobbit
trilogy and he's lent his talent to the
Star Wars sequel films as supreme leader
snoke but he's perhaps best known for
his portrayal of Caesar
the tragic protagonists of the Planet of
the Apes films thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]